[Musique]
J'aimerais que tu puisses
nager comme les
dauphins comme les dauphins peuvent
nager pour
rien nous les
chasserons nous pouvons
les battre juste pour un
jour oh nous pouvons être
des héros juste pour un
jour
[Musique]
oh je serai
roi
[Musique]
et tu seras
reine pour
[Musique]
rien qui les chassera
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous pouvons être
là toujours et
à jamais nous pouvons être
des héros juste pour un
jour
oh je me
souviens que
je
me tiens près de
la mer au-dessus de mon
[  La musique] ne
dirige rien
avant
rien et la
honte était de l'autre
côté [Musique] oh nous pouvons
les battre pour toujours et
[Musique]
toujours nous pouvons être
des héros juste pour un
jour que dire
[Musique]
nous pouvons être
elle nous  sois
[Musique]
elle juste pour un
jour
[Musique] [Musique]
avant [Musique
]
spee [
Musique]
spee
dans
[Musique]
PR et cet
étranger [
Musique] [
Musique]
speee
[Musique]
pour
toi
[Musique]
spee
le
SM
sin oh
[Musique]
long [
Musique]
[Musique]
boee tu as
dit à
[Musique]
juste
s juste
s et [
Musique]
garde
[Musique]
sur
garde
[Musique]
fille
[  Musique]
oh bénédiction,
dis
[Musique]
juste
juste et je
[Musique]
continue [
Musique]
va juste en ch un autre
[Musique]
un juste elle [
Musique] [
Applaudissements] [
Musique]
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[  Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
oh [Musique
] [Musique
] [
Musique]
a
[Applaudissements] [Musique
]
n [Musique
] [
Applaudissements] [Musique] [Musique
]
n [Musique]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements  ]
oh
[Musique]
a
oh [
Musique]
mon SP [
pour
spee
[Musique]
foree
oh
j k v est
M
[Musique]
King à bientôt
alors
[Musique]
et
[Musique  ]
peut-être que tu
ne
viendras jamais si
jamais tu viens à
moi à quoi sert
mon
merveilleux rêve et pourquoi me laisseraient-ils
[Musique]
où me laisseraient-ils
sans
toi pour que [
Musique]
sache savoir
[Musique]
façon d'appeler  c'est pour moi lundi mais mardi
c'est tout aussi
mauvais qu'on l'appelle
lundi Mardi est tout aussi mauvais Mercredi empire quand
jeudi arrive
tu devrais me voir Je suis vraiment triste et je vole
un vendredi Samedi je sors et
je joue à l'aigle qui vole un vendredi un
samedi je sors et je joue le dimanche je vais à l'
église me mets à genoux et je
prie bien je pleure Seigneur aie pitié de moi
oui je le fais je pleure Seigneur aie pitié Seigneur aie
pitié de moi mon bébé  m'a quitté et maintenant je suis
dans tellement de misère
[Musique] l'
aigle vole un vendredi samedi je
sors et joue à l'aigle vole un vendredi
samedi je sors et joue dimanche je vais
à l'église aide-moi j'appelle Seigneur aide-moi
dimanche je  va à l'église Seigneur, aide-moi
à pleurer, aide-moi tous dimanche, je me mets à
genoux
[Rires]
en pleurant mais ce que je veux faire aujourd'hui, c'est que je
veux que tout le monde ici chante ça avec
moi, tu vas juste le faire comme ça
Seigneur  aide-
moi Seigneur, aide-moi
Seigneur, aide-moi, je vais te dire
comment remédier à ton cœur parfois parce que
nous traversons tous des
expériences douloureuses et je vais te montrer exactement
quoi faire en premier J'ai appelé ma mère j'ai
dit Maman j'ai besoin  toi pour m'aider tu vois je me
suis levé ce matin et j'ai même fait
tout ce que
je oui ta maman a dit une chose à faire j'ai
dit qu'est-ce que c'est Maman j'ai besoin de ton conseil
elle a dit crie aide-moi crie aide j'ai
raccroché le téléphone  sur maman et j'ai appelé
mon frère, j'ai dit frère, j'ai besoin de ton
aide, tu es un homme, tu peux me dire quoi
faire, tu vois, il est parti avec tout ce
que je portais et il m'a laissé en bleu, mon
frère a dit que je ne peux pas le dire mais  une chose que j'ai
dit qu'est-ce que c'est, il a dit que tu devais
crier et crier et m'aider
Seigneur, aide-moi J'ai raccroché au nez de mon frère
et j'ai pris l'
avion Je suis allé à Rome tu vois j'ai dit que je
connais quelqu'un qui peut m'aider et  alors je suis
allé au
Vatican, je suis allé à l'interdiction et j'ai frappé
à cette
porte, personne n'a répondu, j'ai dit que je vais frapper
encore jusqu'à ce que le pape réponde à cette porte
et j'ai encore frappé
et que sais-tu, c'était le pape, j'ai
dit que j'avais besoin de pape  toi pour me donner de l'espoir le
pop a dit qu'est-ce que c'est mon enfant j'ai dit que mon
homme m'a quitté Pape il m'a laissé seul en
bleu Je ne sais vraiment pas quoi faire j'ai dit ce
n'est pas pour une raison Seigneur aide-
moi Seigneur
Seigneur Seigneur aide-moi alors  Je dis à l'esprit du
Seigneur, aidez-moi à
toucher mon cœur, vous tous, laissez-moi
réel le P de Dieu
parti, je suis à nouveau heureux, vous voyez ouais, cet
homme m'a quitté mais j'ai été libéré
[Musique]
libre
V
[  Musique]
la
[Musique]
a [
Musique] [Musique
] n [Musique]
n [
Musique]
pap [Musique
] [Musique
]
n [
Musique]
a
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Je n'ai jamais fait  tout mais je le vois à
la télévision, je peux le voir tous
les jours, celui-ci est vraiment moi, ma
peau, j'ai un problème avec
aujourd'hui, fille, Stand By Me, nous
sommes à nos côtés,
toi, fille, Stand By Me,
j'espère que nous  nous vivons dans
[Musique], il
n'y a pas de solution pour avoir la tranquillité
d'
esprit et j'ai dû être
humain Dan un fut dansant
ouvert juste
aujourd'hui, fille, reste à
mes côtés, nous vivons dans
[Musique]
chronométrant
dans
[Musique]
petite fille  Stand By Me, reste près de
moi, nous sommes
[Musique]
dans petite fille Stand By Me et serre-moi
fort, nous sommes penchés
dans
[Musique] à
ce moment-là,
temps, temps
et [Musique]
tu te
lèves [
Musique]
avant
[Musique]
speee
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avant avant
[Musique] [Musique
] [Musique
]
avant [Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
show
mer mer
L one more time one more
[Musique]
temps
étranger [
Musique]
[Musique]
pour
avant [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant